all right mom I gotta go I have to pick
Jackson up and I gotta find my phone yes
I realized I'm on the phone we are
supposed to tell mommy when it's
somebody's birthday because now we don't
have a gift for Jessica and she's gonna
think I'm a bad mommy oh you still play
with this tag still on it gross cool
coffee and there's yesterday's what I
don't feel like washing a blast hey yeah
I'm on my way yeah I'm in the car
already yeah no no I'll be there
oh I'll be there in a second uh-huh yeah
no totally all I remember the muffin
squirt oh this is bony already had
where's your other shoe
what oh my god oh my god I'm on my way
comes late
oh my god god damn it get on these keys
we're late
get in the car oh god what is that
Oh still in my pajamas
whatever who has time to make muffins
for a bake sale anyway right
Karen share it okay one Oh stole bullet
ladies
Linda hmm Karen's a real [ __ ] - I'm
saying Oh me Karen I do kegels every
Biggles every damn such a good mom I've
never dropped my kids